[Music]
thank you
today I feel
Qatari
Arab
today I feel African
today I feel gay
today I feel disabled
today I feel
a migrant worker
[Music]
that was gay disabled Qatari migrant
worker and FIFA president Gianni infanto
Infantino
telling us that he's a little bit of
everything and who isn't during day two
of pride month people oh my God if your
genitals are still attached to you
you're a lucky person uh I'm Dave Rubin
this is still the Reuben report we have
not transitioned and uh it's Friday so
we got a round table Extravaganza for
you joining me today is the
editor-in-chief of the post-millennial
Libby Emmons and CEO of Becker news Kyle
Becker welcome back to the Ruben report
guys thanks thank you Dave first off it
is pride month and I just want to know
how are you guys celebrating Libby you
first how are you celebrating this very
exciting 30 days of pride month uh I
think I'm gonna celebrate by um perhaps
uh cutting my kids genitals off you know
I think that's really the way to go wow
going right for the kids you're really
trying to get a gold star well President
Biden came out just the other day and
said that it was really important to
make sure that kids had the health care
they need what he means of course by
this Health Care is child sex changes
and uh you know I think it's the
Patriotic thing to do so let's go for it
Kyle that's going to be tough to beat
because she's going right for child
genital mutilation so what do you got
well in my uh victimhood competition
here my feminine side is a lesbian so
I'm feeling a little gay myself and I
don't really have a pride month I I have
pride every month so this is more like
narcissism month for me so I'm just
gonna like wrap ratchet it up a little
bit you know and get a little more fruit
for a little more colorful as as it goes
on wear some Flair you know fair enough
fair enough all right well uh we're
gonna recap uh the week that was in
politics and culture wars and all that
stuff but I wanted to start off actually
with one kind of serious story this was
breaking yesterday and it doesn't seem
like it's making its way up to
mainstream media yet I want to read a
tweet from Charlie Kirk then we're going
to show you a little video as well uh
here we go according to reports Jamie
Foxx is now quote paralyzed and blind
from a blood clot in his brain after
receiving the covid-19 vaccine those of
us who spoke against the MRNA shot were
attacked in every imaginable way I am
infuriated infuriated a decent person
like Jamie Fox fell victim to Big Pharma
because a movie set is still dumb enough
to mandate their Cash Cow clot shot okay
so let's remove his editorializing for
just a moment it sounds like something
really is up with actor Jamie Foxx AJ
benza who's an independent journalist
been doing this for for many decades
it's broken many stories over the years
he went on Dr Drew's show and explained
a bit more about what seems to be going
on I work my off to get a story about
why what happened to Jamie Foxx because
it was all baloney but they were
reporting he's playing pickleball he's
responding on Instagram no he's not
people do that for you it's all lies I
had somebody in the room who let me know
that Jamie had a blood clot in his brain
after he got the shot he did not want
the shot but the movie he was on he was
pressured to get it this movie is doing
with Cameron Diaz and I'm thinking is
that why he blew up on the set a week
before this medical emergency happened
is that why he fired three or four
people because he just had had it with
these mandates I don't know but what I
found out from the man in the room was
that uh the blood clot in the brain
caused him at that point to be partially
paralyzed and blind
okay so I can't speak to the the truth
of this uh of of this any more than you
guys can AJ benza he's been around
forever he's broken a lot of stories I
like and Trust Dr Drew so he put him on
so I'm guessing Dr Drew did some due
diligence on this but so let's just go
with the information we have for a
moment uh Kyle you were like one of the
most outspoken people online against
what was going on uh with covid-19 kind
of from the beginning but even now uh I
take it this does not surprise you
no I mean it does surprise me in terms
of we haven't seen a lot of cases of
high profile uh younger guys I know he's
55 years old
um but in terms of the data I was always
surprised that we blew back by the fact
that young healthy adults were never
really at that grave a statistical risk
people without underlying heart
conditions or uh asthma or or so on so I
really felt like you know the mandates
for younger people uh you know forget
the ethical issues on top of everything
else but the younger people I didn't
really uh see a lot of statistical
evidence for making such a strong push
to get uh people who might have natural
immunity might have antibodies already
um might not be a serious statistical
risk uh otherwise healthy I just got a
report out the other day the Ministry of
Health in Israel in response to a legal
request could not confirm firm any young
healthy adults people between 18 and 49
dying specifically of covid just covid
so the Jamie Foxx thing I don't know if
he's partially blind I don't know his
health status any more than you like you
said Dave
um but putting people at risk with no
liability protection at this point uh
you know you can't there's nobody to sue
but they're leveraging our you know
livelihoods against us in some cases you
know like uh media companies you know
some that I work for Fox News for
example uh other companies have made a
push to get people uh vaccinated whether
they had natural immunity or not or
whether they needed it statistically or
not
um this should have been left up to the
doctors and uh if Jamie Foxx didn't want
it the way Dr Peter McCullough
supposedly uh you know counsel them
about this if he didn't want it he
should have been able to get a waiver
easily and and doctors should have work
should work with people they this you
know to get waivers right so so Libby
one of the things that really woke me up
to all of this you know and I was pretty
well I was certainly against mandates
always and I was neither here nor there
on the vaccine I just wanted more
information I did not get vax but one of
the things that really red pilled me on
it was when they were demanding that
employers demand that their employees
get vacced and I'm sitting in a room
usually with people in their 20s and 30s
thinking what right do I have to tell
them what they're going to inject
themselves with it's a little unclear to
me the timeline on this but it sounds
like he got injected because of a movie
that maybe he's shooting right now with
Cameron Diaz which that the fact that
that could still be going on is just
mind-blowing
well I think the unions in LA are still
pretty gung-ho on the vaccine I know
that that's still true for theaters on
Broadway Theater companies they're still
doing it some places you go they're
still forcing people to mask the thing
that I find so disconcerting about this
situation with Jamie Foxx and as we see
other headlines that are like you know
such and such athlete young healthy dies
suddenly on the field heart condition
suspected things like this what's really
disconcerting is that during the
pandemic so much information about the
vaccine and potential risks and concerns
was suppressed we saw people banned
across social media for speaking out and
just citing their statistics from the
government this is a government database
of voluntary reporting on vaccine risks
from doctors
we also heard from doctors saying that
they didn't feel like they were able to
speak out doctors who said that they
didn't even report risks and things like
that to theirs so you know the real
issue is that we don't know if there's
anyone to trust on this data we don't
have any reason to believe that we're
getting accurate information about the
risks and we also don't have reason to
believe that we're even getting or have
recorded accurate numbers of coved
because we saw also during the pandemic
you'd see someone going to the hospital
with a gunshot wound and then his death
was recorded as covet because he died
with covid even though he obviously died
from getting shot right and as Kyle just
referenced this study out of Israel I
mean literally zero people 18 to 49 that
they found died exclusively of kovid not
three not seven zero people Kyle I
assume we're all sort of past the point
where we think anyone's going to pay for
any of this like the ship has just kind
of sailed I mean people will pay
personally like Jamie Foxx is paying
right now but I mean the people who are
to blame for all of this
yeah I've tried over and over again you
know you and I were with uh you know
Governor DeSantis a couple of months ago
and one of the things that I thought
that I've been trying to argue to people
is that at the beginning yeah they
clearly committed fraud uh the CDC
recently uh divulged like I believe it
was April 2020 that they had a meeting
and like there was covid transmitted
among that population in April 2020 uh
do I have that right I think so no 221
sorry um okay so it was early on in the
shots right
and all the majority of them were
vaccinated they just said in a statement
that was this this last week so that
means that they lied that they never
prevented transmission it wasn't just
that the variance escaped the
transmitting blocking supposed mechanism
that they didn't investigate as we heard
from the Pfizer rep in in Europe before
the European Parliament they never
investigated it but they keep telling
you can go to the CDC right now that you
can look up on their website where they
tell they tell you to get vaccinated to
help your community and help your family
they don't help anyone it's an
individual patient-centric thing so it
always should have been an individual
patient decision in consultation with
your doctor with no mandates no coercion
and uh you know personalized risk uh
assessment but unfortunately we couldn't
do that and you know they mucked up the
water really good it was a huge
propaganda operation obviously smoke
screen that just you know and and poor
Americans who aren't very scientific
typically literate they they can't make
heads or tails out of this so you know
if you're not a doctor but you know
statistics and you go and look at the
statistics and you report them and tell
them this doesn't add up you know that
they won't listen to you because you
don't have a white lab coat on like
Libby I got one more slightly different
angle on this story but I I'm pretty
sure that if someone was to jump on
CNN.com right now or msnbc.com or
Washington Post blah blah blah they're
not going to see this story now again I
don't know if it's fully true we'll find
out about that but uh can you just talk
a little bit since you're the editor at
post millennial about just the media
version of all of this where because
this doesn't fit the narrative that the
vaccines are perfect the media will go
out of its way to ignore it or you would
think that if this is a completely made
up story they would be running a story
debunking it because they love debunking
the lies of you know the anti-vax people
yeah I mean certainly The Washington
Post the New York Times none of these
Outlets want to CNN want to run stories
contradicting the Biden administration's
narrative on covid or on the vaccine
that's been clear for a long time that
being said this is just one man's source
and the family has uh the Jamie Foxx's
daughter has said that
um it's not true so it is hard without
corroborating evidence to just go on one
man's story that being said the
Washington Post the New York Times CNN
are constantly citing Random Acts
Anonymous Resorts from somewhere or
other so um it's not like that's really
probably their concern uh it's more
likely that they just don't want to run
anything about a prominent uh beloved
celebrity who has been injured from a
vaccine that the man who is running for
president for a second term continues to
declare is safe and wholesome for
everyone from infants all the way up to
your elderly great-grandmother right and
by the way Trump is on the campaign
Trail right now I think he was in Iowa
yesterday talking about how still he's
so happy about the vaccines but we'll
get tomorrow on the campaign stuff in
just a moment but it is pride month
everybody uh I saw this video yesterday
Canadian flags have been replaced
outside of the Office of Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau with yes you guessed it
the ugliest flag in the history of
humanity the Gay Pride flag take a look
hey Casey here live on Wellington Street
that's Parliament Hill behind me and
directly in front of me is the prime
minister's office and the privy Council
and
guess what is flying here take two
guesses here we'll flip it around show
you the sign
here we go
Office of the Prime Minister and privy
Council
no Canadian flags at the door of the
prime minister's office at the front
door on Wellington Street
Libby what I find disturbing about this
I'm obviously for equal rights and you
can do whatever you want as an adult and
all of those stupid qualifiers that
everyone's getting tired of saying
um but to me that flag now represents a
political ideology more than let's say a
sexuality or whatever it was originally
set out to meaning it is a it is a flag
that is based in equity not equality
which is counter to most most of what
western civilization has been built upon
it's into collectivism the the long list
of leftist socialist ideas that seems a
little problematic except that's pretty
much what Justin Trudeau is all about
right
yeah Justin Trudeau fully stands for
this flag I'm surprised that he didn't
put a big old rainbow colored Maple Leaf
right in the center of it and just
change the flag entirely uh but yeah
this is what he's really all about they
have in Canada he's banned conversion
therapy which means that
um you can't tell a child who claims to
have been born in the wrong body that
there's nothing wrong with their body
and they're perfectly healthy and
they're going to grow up healthy and
things will be fine
um you there's hate speech in Canada
where you can't misgender under penalty
of law you can take someone to the Human
Rights Commission for misgendering you
apparently uh yeah this is what Canada
is all about Canada is all about equity
and Justin Trudeau's ego and um you know
Pomp and uh
presentation and they don't really care
about their citizens these are the same
people that were dragging people out of
homes during coven because there were
five people in a home instead of four so
you know he makes a a big point about
equity and all of this but where
citizens are concerned their rights are
being curtailed he's pushed through a
big censorship bill for Canadian speech
online that's actually affecting a lot
of Facebook traffic and pages and things
like that so we know what Justin Trudeau
really stands for it is something much
more along the lines of authoritarian
authoritarianism political ideology and
no concern for Canadians actual ranks
Kyle there was a little known psychology
Professor out of the University of
Toronto back in 2016 known as Jordan
Peterson who was warning that these
pronoun laws that they were trying to
pass I think it was Bill I always forget
it was Bill c-16 or 17. I always forget
it was 16 or 17. uh what was it I'm
pretty sure it was 16. 16 okay so Bill
Cece 16 and everyone said oh you're
crazy you're a conspiracy theorist
you're a nut bag Flash Forward eight
years here we are
well I think the interesting thing about
this rainbow flag push everywhere is
that it's a passive aggressive attack on
religion and national identity it's not
about inclusion it's not about tolerance
it's not about acceptance because
honestly Christians which is apparently
the target demo that they're trying to
shove this rainbow down their throat uh
they've been very tolerant and accepted
of people you know throughout that
doesn't mean they have to agree with
everything that comes with it and the
same thing should go the other way you
know like gay people don't have to agree
with Christians on everything either so
creating a safe space or a free speech
zone or whatever really means what it
says it's not this one direction thing
where if you question the narrative if
you question rainbow flags being put up
in front of Justin Trudeau's uh prime
minister office and that that makes you
a bigot it makes you hateful no because
they're actually just attacking you this
what critical theory is all about it's
blanket is taking tolerance and kindness
and and happiness and love and
forgiveness and on the inside of it it's
accusations about the white supremacy
structure and all of these other uh
ideas and Notions that they that they
argue systemic racism and so it's it's
this giant ball of uh you know uh you
know of attacking us based on our
identity so like why is our identity not
okay and their identity is okay why
can't all of our identities be okay why
can we when can we just stop pointing
fingers at each other over things that
don't really matter which is really and
what I think a lot of this is about with
the Target and the Bud Light and all you
know and coals and all of this stuff
we're going to be talking about that
instead of Joe Biden not being able to
do anything competently and this
horrific debt ceiling deal and I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure there's no
better there's no better place for gay
people or whatever to live than say a
Canada a United States France things
like that right France is getting tricky
because of their migrant situation also
I think we should start calling him
Pride Minister Justin Trudeau instead of
prime minister Justin Trudeau what do
you think about that I love that he
would love that that he would love that
with his gay socks man right here he
would be thrilled I
he really would all right let's show you
some images here's what's going on in DC
right back here in the good old U.S of a
the trains are gay it's just never
ending and then I did see this one which
I actually really appreciated this is a
random person on on Twitter tweeted out
this image it says LGB don't even want
Pride any pride month anymore we just
want to be separated from the TQ plus
and Elon Musk totally agree and I really
do think that is the sentiment I
personally have nothing to do with these
people I wanted equal rights I've got
them there are no such thing as gay
rights there are equal rights in Western
Society Libby you want to bring us home
on this one
yeah this is something that I think a
lot of gays and lesbians have found
really frustrating is essentially that
the tea has overtaken the entire
movement of equal rights uh for people
with different sexual orientations we
saw recently reported by Katie Davis
Court at the post-millennial that some
crosswalks in Olympia Washington that
are normally Pride crosswalks for June
this year are just the trans flag the
baby pink baby blue and white which of
course infantilizes everyone and was
made by a man who was a fetishist who
forced his wife to take part in these
fetishes
um and if I recall is a bit pedo as well
so that's what we are celebrating when
we pump up this big um this big flag and
it has taken over and I think also it's
really not great for people who are
adults and who are trans and who live
that lifestyle this movement is not
great for them because they're seeing a
whole lot of pushback back most of these
people just want to pass and get through
their lives and exist the way they want
to exist and now they are fully equated
with a movement that seeks to deny
women's rights deny rights for gays and
lesbians and push children into sex
changes so this movement isn't good for
anyone except for people like Justin
Trudeau and pundits and politicians who
use it to gain you know ESG points
yeah and as I often say and I just think
it's worth repeating until everyone gets
it there is no movement that is more
anti-gay than the trans movement exactly
because nobody if there was a group of
Christians that were trying to cut the
genitals off young gay kids we all know
what we would be saying about them
rightly
horrifying right fortifying yeah and
they're also anti-women because they
want women to be had the crap beat out
of them by men but all right let's move
on because Kyle you made a point we're
distracted by these nonsensical issues
related to Target and Bud Light and
everything else there's some other stuff
going on in the country this debt
ceiling deal did get passed and uh house
a majority leader Kevin McCarthy seems
pretty uh pleased with himself here we
go thank you I believe in
Little America first
more than two-thirds of our conference
voted for it
we got all the Democrats who signed a
discharge petition to say they would
never raise the debt ceiling only raise
it clean
we got them to vote for it too so think
about how much further we can go
I told you then it's not how you start
it's how you finish
each week we have stood up for the
American public
be it its strongest border security we
put the citizens of America first
and we didn't do it by taking the easy
way we didn't do it by the ways that
people did it in the past by just
lifting it we decided that you had to
spend less and we achieved that goal
all right before we all jump into that
let's go to another Republican who did
not vote for it Texas Congressman chip
Roy my colleagues be very clear not one
Republican should vote for this deal it
is a bad deal
no one sent us here
to borrow an additional four trillion
dollars
to get absolutely
nothing in return but at best if I'm
being really generous
a spending freeze for a couple of years
that's it
that's about what you get
and frankly you're gonna make things
worse in my Democratic colleagues know
it that's why they're supporting it
that's why they're going around gleeful
like there's a reason our Democratic
colleagues support this there's a reason
that Mitt Romney supports this
there's a reason that bill Crystal
supports this
it's all the same stuff
Kyle it strikes me that they're both
telling the truth to a degree McCarthy's
like hey the Democrats wanted some
really crazy crap they didn't get all
that and then Chip's like no it's still
uh you know low to turd basically
well I'm just I'm just tired of the
gaslighting it just reminds me of like
you're on a tight budget and your wife
goes out shopping and she uses the
credit card that is almost maxed out to
buy you know a dress for 200 and she
comes back and tells you well it wasn't
300 I saved us a hundred dollars no it
you know it's not like we're making
money off of this you're spending uh
money that we don't have on things that
we don't need which is really the
concern of a lot of taxpayers so the
federal budget the funny the interesting
thing about all of this is that you look
at the IRS I think that's a great one
the IRS Staffing so they were able to
cut a a little bit of the budget like 10
like it was like 12 percent of that yeah
it's a proposed budget but the
interesting thing about that is if you
look at the Biden administration's
Arguments for this hiring more agents
over the course of 10 years they want to
recoup 200 billion dollars or so from
the richest people in order to pay for
the climate scan for carbon energy
credits and you know uh green
initiatives and so on so really every
time I try to find something good like
the pay go for example the pay goes like
it means like if you want to change your
budget you have to offset it with
savings but the Biden Administration is
give the budget director is given a
waiver so you know they're just going to
use the waiver whenever they want to
you're never going to be able to pin
them down on that so if you just go one
through one one thing at a time and try
to analyze each one of them it's a
poison pill pretty much every time that
you go through and once again uh you
know not spending more money is not
saving money it's just so spending less
of our money so Libby to that to that
point my heart is with chip here well
actually my heart and my brain are with
chip like this is just more nonsense we
know nothing is going to be resolved or
get better or anything and then the
purely the part of me that just
understands politics is like well
McCarthy if he he doesn't do a deal
basically we know the Republicans get
blamed for it and likely we do end up in
a recession and most of us don't want to
end up in a recession is this just kind
of why politics both sucks and blows
yes it is it is why politics sucks and
blows um but also you have to remember
that 46 Progressive Democrats also voted
against this bill and claimed that you
know Biden had given up too much so this
is another situation where we raise the
debt limit with moderate members of both
parties right taking the Centrist
approach and raising the debt limit so
that we didn't have to deal with
anything else about it that being said
this is one of the most boring news
Cycles it's always boring when we go ask
the credit card companies if we can
please have some more
um and it's going to be like this every
time we're never not going to raise the
debt limit all of this hemming and
hawing about we're going to default and
everything's going to go terribly we
were always going to do this there was
never a question about it so I think
McCarthy did make some gains and I think
that that's useful
um Biden also couldn't keep his whole
party together which I think is
important to note as we head into 2024
he does not not have control of this
party and
um you know people on his side really
don't like him as well well speaking of
speaking of people on his side so check
out you mentioned the 40 some odd
progressives that didn't vote for this
thing uh Jamal Bowman from New York who
is one of the most hysterical like
really nut bags I mean the guy's
basically assaulting people every which
way he can and gotten Thomas Massey's
face and he's always yelling at
everybody and blah blah blah uh here
listen to his rhetoric about this thing
I'm very frustrated you know I I called
on the president to invoke the 14th
Amendment and mint a coin and do not
negotiate with hostage takers I mean we
don't negotiate with terrorists globally
why are we going to negotiate with the
economic terrorists here that are the
Republican Party
okay first off we do negotiate with
terrorists that's that's number one uh
that's number one number two he wanted
to Mint a trillion dollar coin which I I
I'm pretty sure that was an episode of
The Simpsons which almost everything is
but but that's what they think of
Economics oh we can literally just
create a coin and say it's worth a
trillion dollars and do whatever the
hell we want with any everything Kyle I
kind of wish I lived in their world like
what are we all doing
that mad about their conversation they
act like our money is their money that's
that's a that's what they don't seem to
get like their brains their whole way of
looking at at the economy it's it it's
it's all just one shared pot
so you know who cares if we dilute the
pot a little bit by dumping a trillion
dollar coin into it you know and I it's
just it must be wonderful to be so
childlike and naive and like never have
read uh you know history of banking and
money monetary Theory or anything like
this that says that this scam has
basically been going on since the
beginning of money you know through the
Roman Empire through you know debasing
the currencies it's not a new trick it's
been around for a long time and it
almost always leads to ruin you don't
need to be Adam Smith to figure that out
so uh you know it's just like you know I
listen to these people and I just
you know everything is new to them it's
wondrous it's you know we can experiment
and see see if we get inflation oh yes
we're getting inflation and nobody
should be surprised and that's what
happened like to Libby's Point earlier
about you know we're never gonna not
raise the debt ceiling that is true and
we're never going to not stop debasing
our currency until we have massive demon
de-dollarization across the world is as
people just keep dumping dumping the
dollars and uh you know that's gonna
literally I thought of uh negative
things obviously I thought we were the
ones I thought it was those crazy
right-wingers who are always using the
inflammatory language uh he's calling
basically half the country terrorists
yeah they've been doing this for a while
they hate half the country and they're
not afraid to say it and they just
demand that everyone believe that anyone
who opposes Progressive ideology is a
white supremacist even the black people
and Mexicans and from people who oppose
Progressive ideology are racists to
these folks with with an ex I just want
to point that out that was excellent
pronunciation by you let's jump to Let's
jump to one more thing because yesterday
um Joe Biden fell and we are literally
at any moment one second away from
president Kamala Harris so uh I'm sure
most people have seen the video already
but take a look
[Applause]
thank you
you know what Connor I actually want to
throw back to it for one second I want
people to notice that when he tried to
get up initially he could not get up on
his own I don't know if he has any
public appearances today maybe you guys
know can we google that actually see if
he has any public appearances he does
yeah he does have some he's giving a
speech about the debt ceiling deal like
this uh early afternoon mid-afternoon
evening okay I'm glad to hear that the
guy's the president of the United States
I certainly don't want president miles
but could you throw it to it one more
time because I don't think this was as
nothing as it just appears you know if
somebody just trips
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
yeah I mean he wasn't going to get back
up uh Libby look I know none of us are
big on his policies and the people
watching this are not big on his
policies and everything else but but
this is really getting depressing at
some level right
yeah I when I saw this fall I was
actually worried about him we know what
happened when elderly people fall it
often signals a decline that they never
recover from so I was glad to see that
he was able to get up even with help I
was glad to hear that nothing was broken
I do not want president Kamala Harris
she makes absolutely no sense when she
speaks she would just try and solve
things with a bunch of you know
confusing Venn diagrams that only she
understands a whole big laughing about
nothing it would be very confusing so I
do hope that Biden makes it of course as
I'm sure we all do to the uh to the end
of his term
um but yeah whoever put that sandbag
there probably should should not not be
permitted to put things near the
president anymore
um and it was disconcerting that he
wasn't able to get up I think that does
signal some concern about his physical
health that being said he falls down all
the time right I mean we did see the um
that bike accident where he just totally
went down I would prefer a president who
doesn't just go down and have trouble
getting up though
yeah I'm telling you right now my
prediction is this I mean first off
we're a year and a half away so God only
knows what could happen to him in in the
meantime falling whatever else is going
on with him Etc I'm telling you if
DeSantis is the nominee they are
replacing Biden there is no way they
will let him on the stage with Ron
DeSantis they will let him on the stage
with Trump which won't be good either
but that is just my my bold prediction
Kyle like if this was Trump if that had
been Trump everything on CNN for the
next 48 hours would have been 25th
Amendment
yeah I mean the thing about Trump is we
saw how resilient he was when he got
covered and went to the hospital he just
backed like the Undertaker like two days
like boom hitting the hitting the ground
running uh Biden on the other hand if
you look even before the speech at the
Air Force Academy he was wandering
around like backstage he looked like he
just needed Direction and and this is
supposed to be the Commander in Chief he
can't even command a flight of stairs
half the time so like he the way he
falls down doesn't Inspire conference
confidence in the American people it's a
it's an app metaphor for where we are uh
in this country right now and the thing
about Biden getting to the debate I do
wonder if uh you know a lot of that
compromising material the FBI informant
information about the alleged five
million uh five million dollar bribery
scheme involving Ukraine supposedly uh
you know that that sort of backstory
we're gonna see what happens with that
and how much uh you know these Intel
agencies want to go to bat for for Biden
because he's obviously physically
impaired he's uh seems to be ethically
compromised or his family is at the very
least and so we'll we'll see how this
plays out but I mean his health
continues to deteriorate you you've got
to think that some of that material yeah
I'll be watching to see if it comes out
we'll see what happens with the comer
and Raskin and this document that Rey
suddenly wants to to in to show them
redacted obviously but we'll see how
redacted it is right it does it does
seem like if it gets too hot with all of
that they'll they'll just say he's got
Dementia or whatever it is and that'll
be that uh last thought Libby
um it would be nice if another Democrat
would just get up there and say what we
all know to be true but they're just
nobody's going to do it right or do you
think anyone will do it at some point
and just say you know it's time and he's
got to move on
no I think that would be really
detrimental they don't have anyone else
you know there's not anyone waiting in
the wings that can really capture the
hearts and minds of the American people
uh Gavin Newsom you know he's sort of
out there but he's just so awful I mean
he's just such a slimy horrible Man He's
a hypocrite and he's terrible I've heard
some talk about like maybe Andrew Cuomo
wants to take a turn but no one likes
Kamala Harris even after her term as VP
she's horrible like who would they who
would they possibly bring up there to
run what about are really old people
what about what about Michelle Obama I
mean it is pride month so we'll see
that was good I get the meme reference
there everyone will have to think about
it if you didn't quite get what Kyle did
there uh guys happy Pride to you
pleasure having you both on uh we will
do it again soon we got a post game show
for everybody else that
reubenreport.locals.com and if you're
not joining us have a great great
weekend we will be back on Monday ciao
[Music]
foreign